I'm hitting the age at 54 where a lot of
my friends are losing their parents
their parents are passing away they're
heading on to heaven they're graduating
and the stories go from huge amounts of
stress anxiety added grief to the loss
of a loved one and they add to that all
this garbage having to do with the
estate and nobody knows what to do and
everybody's fighting over the china
plate and everybody's fighting over
every little detail it's absolutely
ridiculous and so you you know you need
to have this stuff laid out in detail
and so you sit down with a family and go
this is what the will says this is what
we're going to do so once I was going to
take this part of the business so once I
was going to take this painting so once
I was going to take this and we're gonna
spread the assets out this way and you
know and you know a little Johnny you
got a drinking problem and we're not
giving you any money until the drinking
problem is done it's sitting in trust
your sisters in charge of the trust
until you've been dry for three years or
whatever it is you're going to do but
tell everybody don't leave the burden on
your kids to administrate something that
then their brothers and sisters or their
cousins are mad at them for decades
because they had to do what you told
them to do have a reading of the will
while you're still alive in other words
unpack what's going on in our situation
our business is involved it's
complicated so we literally have a
family meeting and a meeting of our
leadership team once a year where we re
set and adjust and review again the
estate plan where everybody knows what
happens when Dave dies everybody knows
what we do when Dave and Sharon doctor
it's all laid out it's all detailed in
our cases it's micromanagement to the
detail level but you don't have to go
that far all you got to just make sure
you have a written will that fits your
state and you read it to your family and
they know what's up do your well